um
um
thank you
oh
just
uh
yes
it's the bottom line
um
but maybe in the next question
now
two minute warning
alright
all right
what he's here
oh my god
how are you making it
is
[Music]
oh
i am
[Music]
well actually you'd be surprised
it doesn't look cold in here too well
i'm sure uh
things will get heated before uh too
long
sorry for that for the bad joke
[Laughter]
um so let's go ahead and get started uh
we do have some groundbreaking news to
start us off
uh in his very first remarks as
secretary of state
uh secretary lincoln laid out his vision
for strengthening the state department
both in the near term and in the years
to come
in those remarks he acknowledged that we
cannot do our job of advancing america's
interests
values our commitment to democracy
without a state department that is truly
representative of the american people
linking improved diversity and inclusion
to the broader success
of u.s foreign policy today
secretary blinken announced the creation
of a new chief diversity
and inclusion officer position which
will report directly
to him the cdio as it's known will align
and advanced
dni policies across the department bring
transparency
to these initiatives and hold senior
leadership accountable on progress
additionally each of our bureaus will
also designate an existing deputy
assistance secretary
to support that bureau's own efforts and
to serve on a newly created diversity
and inclusion leadership council
bringing senior leaders together from
across the state department to achieve
the goals laid out
in the upcoming diversity and inclusion
strategic plan
diversity inclusion make us stronger
smarter more creative
and more innovative the work of building
a state department that truly
represents the american people is just
beginning
but today's announcement underscores the
secretary's commitment
to seeing it through in other
developments
i'm sure everyone saw secretary of the
secretary's statement this morning
announcing the us intent
to seek an elected seat on the human
rights council
in addition to that statement the
secretary made an address to the council
members today in geneva
to underscore the us determination to
reassert its leadership
in this body hrc elections are slated
for october
of this year with elected members
assuming their seats on january 1st
of 2022 as the secretary made clear
today
this decision aligns with the president
with president biden's determination to
reinvigorate american diplomacy
uh with the foreign policy centered on
democracy human rights
and equality uh so with that um
um i do have some questions about the
diversity and inclusion thing but i
don't have any policy
significant or at least significant
policy questions that i think should
deserve so i will defer
as long as i can reserve the right to
come back i am sure we will be hearing
from you uh
okay i will defer okay uh we'll start
with you myra and we'll go to that
barbara
okay um so on iran um
iran's ambassador in geneva today told
this disarmament
conference again that u.s should go
first
this who should go first thing has been
out there for some time
and we know that some officials don't
see this as a top problem but i'm just
wondering
if the us offer or the willingness to
come back to the table
has an expiration date how long will you
guys
um wait for them to come back to the
table
and then i i'll move on to something
else well uh i think a couple things are
true here camara
uh the first is that as you have noted
we did
uh make clear last week uh after
consultations with
allies and partners over the course of
uh
several weeks uh and then following a
session with the eu
three that the united states would
accept a proposal from the european
union uh
to take part in talks under the offices
of the p5 plus one
uh with iran uh ever since that offer
has been on the table and it has been on
the table
for just about a week now uh we've made
very clear
um that uh questions like the one you
raised today
uh are best addressed in that setting it
doesn't help us to posture
uh from this podium it's certainly uh we
certainly know there is uh posturing
going on
elsewhere uh our intent is to see to it
um and our desire is to see to it that
uh
discussions uh fruitful discussions
together uh with our closest allies and
partners
uh the p5 plus one uh in this case with
principal to clear eye diplomacy
that's where we think these questions
can be best adjudicated and resolved
during that week have you
received any formal or informal
indication signal from the iranians that
they're likely to come to the table i am
not aware that they have changed their
position but obviously that's best
addressed to
uh the iranians uh we'll go to barbara
and andrew
i have a question about navalny as you
please anything else on iran before you
i also have a question on iran why do we
do that
uh so the question on iran is um
as related to what we were talking about
in terms of who should go first
and the um compliance for compliance
is there any consideration of lifting
the nuclear waivers
as part of um a way to get back to talks
um because they also help iran meet its
nuclear
commitments um so is that is that
something that's on the table
i am i'm happy to do the same wind up i
did but i think i will spare everyone
the extra time and just say that again
uh questions about
uh the specifics of um what
might be on the table going forward um
those are all things that we
uh together with our partners would want
to discuss in the context
of the offer we've put forward uh the
offer being to take part in discussions
uh with the iranians in the context of
the p5 plus one
uh relying on that principled clear-eyed
diplomacy
uh in lockstep with our closest allies
um andrew
this isn't going forward this is going
you know to the issue of whether or not
you as a official for the united states
have confidence
that the recordings from those cameras
that are supposed to be held for three
months will
not be violated or raised tampered with
otherwise doctored well this goes back
to the accommodation that was reached
between the iaea
uh and uh iran uh as we said
uh for the past couple days here uh we
fully support uh iaa director general
gracie's efforts to ensure
full implementation of iaea verification
in iran
and we have full faith and competence in
the iaea
we of course
he gave a press statement i believe uh
it was on sunday
uh so when it comes to the accommodation
that uh
he reached with the iranians we would
want to defer to the director general
but
um our general attitude is that we have
full faith and confidence in the
director general and in the iaea
we have any independent way of verifying
that they're not being you know too
accommodating given
that iran maintains access to those
cameras for
three months well i don't want to go too
much into it uh from here obviously but
uh of course the iaea
um uh we have full faith and confident
confidence
uh in its ability and it goes without
saying uh that
iran's nuclear activity is of great
interest to the united states
uh government i think i'll leave it at
that
i'm sorry sure you said that
questions like that are best addressed
in the setting at the table but i think
what she was asking is
is us offered to come to that table in
the first place how long does that last
is there an expiration date which well
what i would say is that
uh this is an urgent challenge for us uh
and by
challenge i'm not uh specifically
referring to a potential return to the
jcpoa
uh in the sense of compliance for
compliance what i'm referring to uh is
the fact that iran
over the course of the past couple years
uh ever since may of 2018 when um
the united states left the jcpoa uh iran
has taken steps
away from the nuclear deal the nuclear
deal that when
it was in effect uh was verifiably and
permanently
uh blocking iran's ability to acquire a
nuclear weapon i think i said this
yesterday but that's not
my opinion um it is uh the opinion of
our intelligence community of this
building of international
weapons inspectors the iaea our closest
allies
uh and partners now with iran having
distanced itself from several of these
key constraints
uh its nuclear program uh has become
more advanced
in certain ways uh one way we look at
that is the so-called breakout time
the time it would take iran to acquire
the nuclear material
required to build a nuclear weapon if
iran chose to do so
uh when the jcpoa was in effect uh that
was at 12 months
um that time was significantly lengthy
from the time when the obama biden
administration
started these negotiations at one point
uh it was measured in a small handful of
months
we are now according to some published
reports back in that time frame of
a few months our goal in all of this
is to uh ensure that we once again have
verifiable
and permanent constraints on iran's
nuclear program
uh and to ensure that iran cannot
acquire a nuclear weapon so
all that to say uh our patience is not
unlimited um but we do believe and the
president has been clear on this ever
since he was running for high office
that the united states and he
felt that the most effective way to
ensure iran could never
acquire a nuclear weapon was through
diplomacy
um that is what we are engaged in now uh
heretofore we've been
engaged in that in those consultations
with our allies
with our partners with members of
congress uh and now as of last week as a
week ago
today i believe it was we put that offer
on the table
that through the under the auspices of
the p5 plus one
we would be willing to engage in that
diplomacy in those consultations
directly with iran together with our
closest allies partners
right here you keep saying that iran was
in complete
compliance with the agreement before may
2018.
but that's not entirely the case because
the way the the way the deal was
structured
if iran came out of compliance for any
reason there was a way for them to get
back into compliance and so in fact
there were
numerous incidents
of non-compliance or what might
uncharitably be called violations
particularly with heavy water production
and storage and when they exceeded on
the heavy water when they exceeded their
heavy water
productions george the u.s and other
countries
stepped in and bought it the excess from
them
which meant that if they violated the
agreement they would actually get paid
for it
so it's all very nice it's all very well
to say that they were
here the great irony of this is that
with the united states
not in the jcpoa we no longer have that
remedial method you're no longer able to
pay the iranians for
violating the agreement oh hold on
you're saying that we
can't go back to the joint commission uh
and
uh make clear uh when we think iran has
come into
violation of the jcpoa um look
i again i would point you to the fact
that uh we have full faith
and full confidence in the director
general of the iaea
full faith and full confidence in the
iaea uh the iaea
while the uh uh iran deal while the
jcpoa
um was in full effect while iran was
abiding by it
uh they expressed confidence that iran
was living up to its limits now
um this is a not an uncomplicated
uh set of issues uh and i know you're
referring to
some of these technical matters um but
uh the iaea
um i certainly wouldn't want to speak to
them but i suspect if you go and ask
them
they will tell you that they were
satisfied um by iran's
compliance with the deal iran was
complying with the deal more importantly
iran was permanently and verifiably
prevented from obtaining a nuclear
weapon
that's what we're going for here you can
you can say that there are technical
issues but you know that that's
the entire agreement hinged on technical
issues right
inspections uh the entire agreement
hinged
hinged on a very simple premise iran
was permanently and verifiably prevented
from obtaining a nuclear weapon you guys
you say it sounds as though you're upset
that you're not able to pay iran
to come after it violates the agreement
you hear those words come out of my
mouth they came out of your mouth so
uh yes kylie um
have you guys been briefed by the iaea
since
uh the weekend so we've seen the iaea's
latest quarterly report on iran
uh it does remain restricted uh until
the iaea board decides they
uh can be released publicly so we're not
going to wait into
uh the details of it okay and then can
we move on to saudi arabia
sure yesterday we are in south korea
what's the message you're giving to us
uh allies and
other countries about iranian assets
does the united states object to
the unfreezing of assets is that
something the united states supports
uh well so on the question of south
korea um we don't have anything new to
announce at this time uh the government
of south korea the rok has made clear
uh it has not released the one billion
dollar uh in funds to iran
uh we remain in ongoing consultations uh
with south korea uh i believe the their
ministry of foreign affairs uh
issued a statement um on this on this
and made clear that the iranian assets
locked in south korea will be released
after
uh only after consultations uh with the
united states
um uh south korea is a vital partner um
south korea
um plays a vital role in sanctions
enforcement uh not only when it comes to
iran um but also
uh to north korea of course
uh look these issues are issues that we
would want to
discuss in the context of diplomas uh
not in the context of
speaking from podiums posturing from
podiums um that is why
a week ago today we put that offer on
the table with our p5 plus one partners
to partake in that diplomacy uh
i heard saudi um yep um i'm curious
about
um special envoy lender king while he's
in riyadh will he have discussions
about the findings in the unclassified
intelligence report
into the murder of jamal khashoggi with
saudi officials
well let me start by saying and i've
said this before
from this podium that the murder of
jamal khashoggi it was a horrific crime
the administration is prepared to
release an unclassified report
um with full transparency for congress
uh this is the law
uh we will follow the law you heard this
from
then dni designate haynes during her
confirmation hearing
and i understand uh now that she is in
charge of the dni as the director of
national intelligence the dni is
um preparing to do just that um when it
comes to details
of that report and details for its uh
release i would refer you to
the dni i i don't think we have anything
additional uh to read out
uh on special envoy linder king's
discussions uh with saudi officials on
this front of course um his
remit is yemen his remit is to
prioritize
diplomatic engagement to uh bring about
again in close coordination with the
human special envoy martin griffis
uh a diplomatic resolution to the
long-running conflict in yemen knowing
that the people of yemen
uh have suffered enormously uh knowing
that yemen is now home to the world's
worst humanitarian catastrophe that is
special envoy linda king's
uh focus uh and that is what he's doing
right now but if the matter comes up
while he's meeting with saudi officials
he's not prevented
from discussing it with them is he i
look his focus is the conflict in yemen
um
i we have um been in touch with saudi
officials
uh at multiple uh levels as you know the
secretary has spoken i believe it is
twice now with his
uh saudi counterpart um the department
of defense read out
a call um with secretary with secretary
austin uh and his
saudi counterpart um so uh it need not
be that
special envoy linderking is uh our only
channel to saudi authorities we have
uh regular regular um discussions uh
with them on a range of issues andrew
sure um andrea
genosaki said that there was going to be
the call
soon there's been some reporting that
it's going to be imminent
as soon as today or tomorrow um
by the president do you have any better
understanding of the timing of the
release
and there's a cnn report and defer to my
colleague from cnn
which traces the airplane used in the
khashoggi
murder back to ownership of the year
prior this is based on court documents
filed in canada
are you aware of that is that
is the state department looking into
that so what i will say is that
uh the dni um has
uh committed to uh release uh an
unclassified version of the support of
congress
i understand that will uh take place
soon i believe that's what my
counterpart jonsaki said today at the
white house press briefing i of course
wouldn't want to weigh in on
any potential calls or consultations
the president might make but the point i
made
prior to the stands that um we have been
uh in touch with
uh saudi officials at numerous levels um
in the
uh early weeks of of this administration
the secretary has done that
uh others have done that from from this
building we mentioned special envoy
linderking
uh we know that has taken place at the
pentagon uh as well
um but i don't have anything else to uh
to to read out there
um when it comes to the details of uh
jamal khashoggi's uh horrific
uh murder uh the dni compiled
a report um essentially um to look at
these
uh these very issues uh so i wouldn't
want to
get ahead of what may be in that report
saudi arabia is being sued by the
families of
uh the victims of the shooting at the
florida military base pensacola
so um you may remember that president
trump
promised the families that the saudis
would pay them are is the state
department encouraging the saudis to
settle this lawsuit
and also this uh the shooter was part of
this military training program that's
connected to
um weapons sales is that is that still
happening that military training program
or have there been any
um uh any steps taken to
increase vetting well as i understand it
the
the specific training program in
question was administered by
the department of defense uh so i would
need to refer you
there but what i would say broadly um is
that as we have said
saudi arabia is a partner across many
priorities including
regional security and counterterrorism
um
uh and professional military education
programs
uh managed by both states and the
department of defense
um help build the capacity of partners
to provide for
their own defense uh to improve
relations and interoperability between
our national forces and those of our
partners
uh and to provide um our own forces with
exposure to
foreign theaters and cultures just as we
advance um us values with our allied
militaries um such as understanding um
uh and respect for human rights and and
the law of armed conflict when
it comes to uh the lawsuit you mentioned
obviously uh
you're asking about pending litigation
uh we don't comment
on pending litigation beyond to say
beyond saying that
our thoughts and prayers of course
remain with the victims and survivors
of this tragic uh attack uh as well as
with their families i refer you to doj
for comments on the litigation can i ask
about navalny as well
sure anything else on saudi great uh
thank you so amnesty international is no
longer calling alexa navalny
a a prisoner of conscience because it
says um
of these comments he made uh
anti-migrant statements he made in the
2000s
reached the threshold of the advocacy of
hatred how does the state department
view mr navalny do you see him as a
prisoner of conscience
uh we view his uh detention as
politically motivated
um uh as we have said um russia
has a abysmal record when it comes to
human rights the detention
of mr navalny is just one element of
that
the detention and the violence
perpetrated against those brave russians
who took to the streets
uh to protest his attention uh is
another element of that but of course
uh those are just two um more recent
incidents
in a long running series of
offenses when it comes to russia's
um uh lack of respect uh for
human rights when it comes to amnesty's
um determination regarding mr navalny i
need to refer you there
um yeah well just returning to the
diversity and inclusion
that you mentioned at the top um is that
going to apply to
just the state department overall in
terms of an entire workforce or is there
going to be an effort made
for the very senior ranks ambassadors
assistant secretaries under secretaries
and such
and then a related question are you
going to be nominating more
you know more senior level uh we have uh
under secretary for political affairs
nominee we have
deputy secretary of state are you going
to be nominating more senior diplomats
as
you know as this administration tries to
engage the world more
to your first question this is a
prioritization uh at all levels
um the secretary has made it clear
that this is a department that
represents
america to the world um this is a
department uh that needs to
reflect uh the full diversity of
uh the american people and he doesn't
see that just as
a virtue he sees it as um
uh as a strategic necessity uh knowing
that if we
are to harness our full competitiveness
our full comparative
advantage uh we have to harness the full
set of strengths
uh of uh the american uh people and
ensuring that we have
a diverse uh inclusive and equitable uh
workplace
um this is true um in um
uh junior level positions just as as it
is at the
very highest positions uh within this
building i can tell you that
um the secretary is absolutely
prioritizing
uh these issues um uh diversity equity
and inclusion
when it comes to uh the uh appointment
or nomination
uh as a case might be of uh senior
officials
uh going forward um there will um
you will see that reflected as the
fuller team comes together
that includes
with assistant secretaries under
secretaries uh and
uh additional nominations and
appointments what's the secretary's
preferred approach
would it be to promote a black american
or person of color or other minority
from the career staff to a senior
leadership position in the department
or to bring out to bring in someone an
outside
you know an outside political appointee
as we've seen well i think the approach
is to harness
uh our full uh national strength uh
and we are grateful to have within this
building
some of the most experienced capable
individuals on any given region or
functional topic as the case might be
and so for that reason i think as these
appointments and nominations go forward
you will be hearing a number of names
who are career officials
uh who are foreign service or civil
service in many cases have spent
years and even decades in this building
that will be the case at
uh within with some of the highest level
positions
uh here uh now of course um there may
also be some positions where
um uh someone with an outside
perspective uh brings
uh unique strengths uh and so i think
the
north star as it were will be to
leverage
our full strength and to choose the
people who are
best suited for those particular jobs
but in many cases you will be hearing
from the secretary or from the president
in the case of the nomination that uh
the person best suited for a particular
job will be a career official
the policy should take priority over
that i cannot i i just ask you i mean
how exactly is this
cdio going to
incorporate diverse diversity and
inclusion at every level
is it just with appointments is there
more no it is about a workplace culture
and of course nominations and
appointments are key to that
um but it is about um building
um and strengthening a culture uh
within this building that is consistent
uh with the culture that
the president united states and the vice
president united states and of course
secretary lincoln himself
uh wish to inculcate um uh
in the case of those first two across
the federal government and in the case
of secretary lincoln of course
at the united states and the second
point i would uh in the case of the
state department i should say
um uh the second point i would make is
that it's about um
holding us accountable um holding senior
leadership
accountable uh for making progress um
how exactly do you hold well
for one uh you give this individual
uh direct access to the secretary to the
seventh floor
um this individual will as i said before
report directly to
the secretary of state um because the
secretary of state wants the
unvarnished view of how we are doing
against that metric of building a
diverse
equitable and inclusive uh workplace
recruiting and retaining
a workforce that fully represents uh the
united states
uh of america i also mentioned um in the
in the topper and the secretary
mentioned in a statement
it is about uh designated uh at the das
level at the deputy assistant secretary
of state level
an individual within each bureau to help
um uh
track uh progress to represent
that bureau um within uh the uh
diversity and inclusion uh council
um and so this will take place at
multiple levels but i think importantly
um the secretary will be hearing
directly from a direct report
about the progress we are making against
the school the the
the thing that i the reason i'm asking
this is because i've been doing this a
long time some
people i think probably say too long but
since i've started covering this
building this has been a constant
request
for every administration starting with a
clinton administration
okay and now we have a such and and and
and it never seems to get any better and
in fact report after report comes out
you know every year saying it's less
diverse it's not
represented um and now we have a
situation where the president of the
united states
actually happened to have been the
number two
of the country the entire country for
eight years
and the deputy and and the secretary of
state
happened to have been the deputy
secretary of state for four years why
didn't they do something
then about this why is it
you know it's not as if they weren't in
positions of leadership
before uh prior to four years ago
why wha why now why all of a sudden
now this has been a problem that's gone
back decades
why why why why why didn't they do
something about it then
well i think the short answer is that
they did um and in fact there was a
presidential memorandum sign
uh to this very effect but the more
important point
is that no one is satisfied uh with the
progress that was made then
nor with where we are now um that is
precisely why we are taking these steps
the step that
the secretary announced today um i
i don't believe that that this
department has ever
had before a chief uh diversity uh and
inclusion
office or an officer um report directly
to the secretary of state
on these issues i don't believe matt
that this department has ever before
designated
uh deputy assistant secretaries within
each bureau to track this issue i think
um when you look at our approach um it
will be different
from the approach that previous
administrations have taken and i think
um that it is our hope and uh it is our
expectation uh that we will
uh make progress um where progress
before has has not been
okay well i i wish them luck but i
you been in government for a while and
so you know that
adding a layer of bureaucracy or a a one
position
isn't always a you know it's not always
a panacea for it can i ask one more
question about it's unrelated to this
but i'll let someone go but it's back
you went the human right
i can wait um anything else on this
no okay go ahead and we'll move on
oh you want me to go um yeah so uh on
the uh hcr so yes he did
uh announce that you guys are going to
see creation um
how how how uh ardently are you going to
campaign for this uh for this post
well i don't think we would announce
that we're going to seek a seat um
and then not well you mean you're gonna
try someone to try and push someone else
in the uh
you know you know what we og means right
i i do i do
right so you're gonna try and kick
someone else out uh look
we are um i'm not going to
uh discuss private diplomatic
conversations i think uh
the fact is that we are privileged to be
a part of a regional group
um where all those uh that have
announced their
candidacies uh have a shared determined
commitment to
advance and protect human rights um i
think
we are running for a seat or we will be
running
uh for a seat for um a very simple
reason i think
when you hear the secretary he often
puts it
this way when united states isn't
in a leadership role when we aren't um
galvanizing collective action one of two
things happens
and neither of them uh are good for our
interests or our values
uh either no one steps up and chaos
ensues
uh or potentially worse uh an adversary
of ours or a competitor
of ours uh seeks to fill that uh that
void
and our interests and our values are uh
worse off because of it we have seen
instances of that
um of both of those outcomes in recent
years
um what we are doing today in the
context of the human rights council
in the context of issues and challenges
across the board
uh is that we are stepping back up um
america is back
as the president put it before the
munich security council
uh last friday uh and america's back
because we know that when we are
at the table we can shape developments
events institutions in a way that we
could not
when we are absent um and that is
precisely uh what we
plan to do here uh yes i've seen your
hand up for a while yes
thank you um i'm christina from the
german press agency bpa
i have a can you hear me or actually i'd
like your phone
um i have a question concerning
appointments and nominations but germany
related it's about the
u.s ambassador to to germany because
this position has been vacant for quite
a while since june
uh i know it's not top priority
obviously but could you still give a
rough timeline for when
a nomination could be expected there
given this long vacancy given the
declared wish to revive
partnerships with european um allies and
also before richard grinnell took office
in 2018 i think there was a vacancy for
about 16 months so is that something
a timeline that germany has to brace for
or is it gonna be a little quicker
well let me start by saying uh when it
comes to our relationship our bilateral
relationship with germany that germany's
important
uh u.s ally of course an economic
partner
as well uh rebuilding and strengthening
uh the u.s germany relationship it's a
priority for this president
uh it's a priority for this secretary of
state uh our relationship with germany
is built on shared values
of freedom of democracy human rights
the rule of law and that is why
of course the role of our ambassador
to germany will be so important i
discussed this yesterday in a separate
context
um another um important uh
uh diplomatic post but uh the same is
true uh
ambassadorial nominations are
nominations of the president united
states
um and so uh that uh uh
process um will uh is administered
um by the white house of course in
consultation with um the secretary of
state and the department of state
um i think it is um uh absolutely
uh true and you can expect um that any
uh when we do have
an announcement of a nominee for
ambassador germany that person
uh will have uh the trust not only of
the secretary of state um but also of
the president himself um given how
important this diplomatic
post is for us michelle we have
a readout for the secretary school with
uh omani foreign minister
and uh are you planning to use oman as a
venue to talk to the iranians again
uh so we i don't have anything to to
read out just yet
um if we do have something uh later
today we will uh we will let you know
uh when it comes to timing when it comes
to venues
uh for um potential uh uh
discussions with iran in the context of
the p5 plus one
um all of that is still to be worked out
um
uh so i don't have any more uh for you
there obviously amman has played
an important role uh in the past um uh
we're grateful for that but i don't have
any
uh update uh there um yes
okay sorry um but there there's just a
report out saying that the us and israel
are going to reconvene
um a strategic working group on iran to
discuss
intelligence and that the meetings the
first meeting could take place the next
few days
do you have any comment on that i don't
have a comment specifically on that i i
would
um note more broadly that
this administration and the president
biden's commitment to
israel's security is ironclad you
of course know that from his time as
vice president
when now president biden played an
important role
negotiating the 2016 memorandum of
understanding on security assistance
security assistance which at the time
and still today
uh was the largest commitment to
security assistance in u.s
history uh under the terms of the 38
billion dollar
mou signed by the united states and
israel in 2016.
um we set funding for israel at levels
of 3.3 billion dollars
um in fmf uh in foreign military
financing
uh and 500 million dollars for
cooperative programs for missile defense
uh per year
uh over a period of uh 10 years which is
how you get to that 38 billion dollar
uh figure uh harris administration will
uphold uh
the commitment in the 2016 mou without
reservation
um and uh um we will also take action
uh when it comes to our shared
challenges uh
in coordination uh with our allies and
partners to deter
and to counter uh iran's destabilizing
activities its malign uh
influence in the region there should be
no doubt
that israel can count on uh the united
states and we do
remain committed to the idea of israel's
qualitative
military edge consistent with u.s
law so of course there will be that
close coordination going forward
um so mr blinken talked about consulting
with
the saudis and the israelis on iran
policy so
how important would this close type of
consultation as
as would happen in this strategic
working group which existed before
of course how important is that kind of
close consultation
to this the your strategy for iran
well consulting with our um partners and
allies it's critical
uh to our strategy to iran but
especially for israel because
the israelis um have a what do you what
do you say here a dog in the fight or
whatever of course of course i i
we have
especially since the israelis have been
have been talking about how to
not follow your strategy actually
they've been talking about
um the the dangers of going back to the
jcpoa so
what what what is this in particular
important for how your strategy evolves
well we have committed to consult
closely um with our partners and allies
um including those uh in the region um
uh of course the p5 plus one was the
body that
uh ultimately uh culminated or
consummated i shouldn't say
uh the jcpoa um uh the jpoa in 2014 the
jcpoa in 2015.
um uh but of course as you mentioned
there are
um countries in the region close u.s
allies and partners
that do have a profound stake in this
with israel
um being one of them uh and so that is
why we are
um we have committed uh to undertaking
those consultations
and consulting closely with our israeli
partners going forward you've seen that
um now in a couple calls between
secretary lincoln
uh and foreign minister ashkenazi you of
course saw that the president himself
spoke to prime minister netanyahu that
close coordination and consultation is
taking place in multiple
multiple levels um yes please
one question on iran and one on europe
and iran i wanted to know if you could
get any updates on the negotiation
going on for the u.s citizens who are
our stage in iran
and are you going to make the release
key of um of the
of your iran policy are we going to
answer
to make the release key of a part of
your yeah
i think um so on the um
us citizens who are uh unjustly uh
detained uh in iran um
we have no higher priority uh than their
uh
safe uh and expeditious uh return our
strong message
as i believe we said to the iranians uh
is that we won't accept
um uh their continued detention uh in an
unjust
and a wrongful manner it's a significant
priority for this administration to get
them home safely
um you heard from national security
adviser sullivan
over the weekend on sunday that the
united states has uh conveyed
uh this message uh to the iranians
um when it comes to these these issues
uh the nuclear issue
uh and the safe return of the americans
who are
wrongfully and unjustly held look we
don't want to
tie their face uh to an issue um
that is complex and that is challenging
um
and that may be
a longer term proposition we want uh to
make clear
that their safe return home is an urgent
priority for us
um and it is something that um as
the national security advisor said um we
have made very clear to the iranians
themselves
so just on europe um do when president
biden starts traveling again do we know
which country in europe it will uh go
first could it be france for instance
so yeah it's a the million uh million
euro question i suppose um
i know look we don't have any updates on
on travel
um what we have said uh is that
uh the secretary uh will start traveling
um when it is safe to do so when it is
safe for
those who would be accompanying him when
it is safe for those who would be
meeting him
uh on the other uh side uh and so as
soon as we have an update there
um we'll let you know when it comes to
timing and also of course when it comes
to location uh
final question sean it's about uh
burma slash myanmar malaysia has
deported
over 1000 uh myanmar citizens back
uh rights groups have been criticizing
that does the united states have any
comments or concerns we do and we are
concerned by the reported deportation of
nearly
1100 burmese nationals from malaysia uh
this in spite of a malaysian court order
barring
their deportation uh and in light of
ongoing
unrest in burma uh that of course has
been taking place since the coup
of february first uh we continue to urge
all countries in the region
contemplating returning burmese migrants
back to burma
to halt those repatriations until the
unhcr can assess whether these migrants
have any protection concerns
uh before being sent back to burma
noting that the burmese military has a
long
documented history of human rights
abuses uh against members of religious
uh and ethnic minority minority groups
uh as for the united states
uh we will continue um life-saving
humanitarian assistance
to vulnerable populations in need uh
including uh
those uh in the region you had a second
question
okay i don't want to thank you
there's just one other thing a group of
ngos just has been calling for
um an arms embargo at the u.n level on
uh
on myanmar um obviously that's something
the us individually supports but
is there uh some push that you intend uh
at the u.n level to make that uh
we've been pushing on this issue um uh
within the u.n since
the early hours after the february first
coup uh the united states of course was
uh pivotal uh to the statement you saw
emanate from the u.n security council
uh in the days after uh in the days
after this we've been pressing
individual u.n security council uh
members both uh publicly and privately
uh to
um uh condemn uh what has taken place
and to
join us and to join our like-minded
partners and allies
uh in pressing for the restoration of
civilian-led leadership in burma
uh and in standing uh with the people of
burma uh in their
uh aspirations for a return to democracy
final question here
um if my voa colleague asked you about
this
whether the united states received
formal requests
from the burmese diplomats in the us who
are asking for asylum
he said you were going to go back to her
did you guys have an update uh so that
is an issue that i would need to refer
you to dhs um they of course uh handle
uh asylum claims
um it means i would need to refer you to
the department of homeland security
so the department of homeland security
is looking into it
the department of homeland security is
the department that adjudicates such
claims
when they're made inside the united
states correct
if they are made outside but the
question was so all right well then let
me ask this
how did any burmese diplomats come to
u.s missions overseas seeking stuff
uh don't refer me to dhs because it's
not
there i would not in that context uh the
question yesterday was have birming's
in the united states um requested asylum
i'd refer you to dhs
if there's anything more we can share on
burmese diplomats who have requested
asylum around the world
we will let you know thank you very much
see you all tomorrow
right
we are privileged to we are privileged
to operate within uh
fortunately when it comes to all these
countries we share
very similar values
[Music]
yeah um
uh what is accurate is that we are
reviewing our relationship
um
reporting about virtual tours when can
we
write about the virtual viewers in
reality
so we will give you uh
we will give you at least uh i would
imagine 24 hours
um well hoping to give you 24 hours
before the actual tour starts um
no no we've always been planning these
um
there's no indication that actual uh
travel planning is moving to the right
um
um
well at some point those two things will
be heard
um because our goal is to
not only have a raw and re-enter
so even as you know the nuclear
diplomacy is on one track right now
um
so what jake said on on sunday is that
um we have made our position clear to
the
alliance
wouldn't want to get into the mechanism
there but you know the point i mean in
the briefing is that um we don't want to
target
the fate of americans to english the
nuclear issue
is good the time frame there is
undetermined
uh it's complex challenging is what is
what is not
complex is the fact that these americans
are being uh
conflicted
we wouldn't want to wouldn't want to go
into anything um the orions know where
we stand
uh obviously other countries um
as far as i know his remains have not
been found um i believe
that previous administration did
conclude um
uh
motivated we stand by that
but it just gets into that
um
[Music]
uh what we have said um is that any
activity
that puts the end state of two-state
solution farther out of reach
israel's identity as a jewish and
democratic state
we're not talking about legality we're
talking
five
[Laughter]